[Musique]
personnes habitait cette maison depuis
que le village a été abandonnée
il
bonjour bonjour d'agde frère c'est elle
qui a fait tout ça oui on dirait bien
qu'est ce que vous allez faire de cette
maison on va la transformer en chambre
d'hôtes en été c'est bourré de touristes
les enfants ne disparaissent pas comme
ça en islande
c'est pourtant ce qui est arrivé à mon
fils béni
je suis la pression qu'ils essayent de
mettez vous en dites quoi est ce que
vous croyez que c'est la même personne
qui a tracé cette inscription
oui c'est du moins le garder oui je
pense que c'est évident cette photo a
été prise
un an avant que l'église ne soit démonté
en 1956 l'église a été démonté et
transporté depuis esteyrie cette croix
est censé être au cimetière est pas
ailleurs il y avait un trou sous sol
comme comme si une croix a été retiré
voilà ses parents la mère berthe 10 et
nss 7 aux tirs est mort qu'à la
naissance de fermeture il ya quelqu'un
[Musique]
selectrip oublie pas du tout mensonge
famille mois
puisque pernod douce vous rappelle
quelque chose ça va bien se passer
pourquoi vous avez dit bizarre pourquoi
vous avez dit ça
[Musique]
je veux m'en aller je veux m'en aller
tissier